nathalie arthaud la candidate de lutte
ouvrière à la présidentielle est notre
invité bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous ce soir la révolution en
campagne donc contre les ravages du
capitalisme c'est bien ça pour vous le
capitalisme ce ne sont que des ravages
nathalie arthaud d'abord à écouter les
chiffres je sais pas la réalité parle
d'elle-même non vous croyez pas le
chômage qui a explosé 11 millions de
femmes et d'hommes en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté en france
dans la cinquième puissance quand même
du monde à nous dit on voilà quatre
millions et demi de chômeurs des gens
qui doivent compter euros après euros
pour remplir leur frigo qui pour
chauffer mêmes doivent réfléchir à
quelle pièce donner la priorité donc oui
c'est une réussite une catastrophe
sociale pour les classes populaires
je parle pas là du monde bernard arnault
de madame bettencourt de monsieur
proglio ou du patron de publicis dont
j'ai d'ailleurs oublié le nom maurice
maurice lévy voilà tu as touché un bonus
à la rémunération différée de ses
aiguilles ont quand même voilà jusque là
mal donc pour eux évidemment j'imagine
bien qu'ils ne voient pas les choses de
la même façon c'est moins difficile dans
ce cas là tout le monde en conviendra
nathalie arthaud vous vous êtes donc
engagé dans votre première campagne
présidentielle après la longue épopée on
va dire comme ça derrière l'aiguillé
dont vous êtes très proche d'ailleurs
être vous conseille un seul jour des
réseaux oui mais suri dans la campagne
bien sûr elle suit tous les jours alors
samir tounsi de l' agence france-presse
puis perrine tarneaud de public sénat
nous rejoindrons tour à tour au cours de
cette émission où est ce que vous
préférez aller d'abord changer de vous
poser cette question sur les plateaux de
télévision ou dans les usines
moi je ne vais pas je fais pas le tour
des usines
quand les travail vente quand des
travailleurs les militants de lutte
ouvrière moi je moi même je suis
monsieur je travaille donc vous êtes
enseignant sur enseignant sera également
l'occasion de la campagne vous allez sur
le pire à l'occasion de la campagne jeu
je réponds aux invitations des
travailleurs qui considère que ma
présence peut leur être utile voilà et
qu' ils ont besoin d'un soutien donc je
leur apporte quand je le peux mais j'ai
pas besoin de faire le tour des usines
mois les les militants mutware sont
dedans sont de tous les combats et voilà
donc c'est pas de façon artificielle si
vous voulez comme j'ai déjà roulé sa
crainte vous n'aimez pas la
personnalisation nous appelons les
marbrières loyers du japon lutte
ouvrière et ce à une raison la raison
c'est que justement nous sommes dans la
classe ouvrière et contient bien moi la
défendre par nous mêmes alors faisant de
la politique justement par en bas vous
aimez haranguer la foule et les
journalistes aussi parce que quand on
vous écoute déjà en un petit aperçu
l'émission ne vient que de commencer et
on sent un baby à ses 101 ans ici je
peux je peux je peux faire moi si vous
vous heureux mais ce que donc ce que je
ce que j'aime en tout cas en campagne
ces documents les meetings ça c'est
certain que dans les meetings on peut
s'exprimer
voilà on peut dire tout ce qu'on pense
expliquer convaincre et on a le temps
donc c'est incroyable une question qu'on
pourrait peut-être poser à tous les
candidats vous allez me répondre et ce
n'est pas l'impression parfois de
toujours répéter les mêmes choses
mécaniquement le palier artaud à ça peut
arriver
hu est arrivé bien sûr oui ça peut
arriver mais en même temps chaque
interview est différent tu voyais avec
vous c'est toujours très original enfin
je compte sur vous pour m'aider alors on
prend le pari pour les quarante minutes
qui nous reste quel est votre modèle de
société d'écouté c'est une société où
l'économie serait maîtrisée par
l'ensemble de la population une société
où on vous vivrait pas cette économie
complètement folle on a l'impression
peut naître dans une maison de fous
quand même un ou plus en produits de
richesse plus on est capable de
fabriquer des profits et moins cela et
rejaillit sur l'ensemble de la
population et sur les travailleurs et
plus c'est même cela devient même
nuisible à toute la société parce qu'on
voit ses profits
ap 1 par la spéculation et on voit ses
profits finalement se retourner contre
tous les toute l'économie par ce qui
entraînait ses profits entraîne
l'économie est bien dans la crise on est
dans une économie
jose louis injuste inégalitaire et
complètement irrationnel
vous ajoutez la génomique capitaliste
est condamné mais à quelle échéance
c'est quoi dans six mois dans dix ans
dans une économie qui creuse les
inégalités qui qui condamne ceux qui la
font tourner au quotidien les
travailleurs a reculé à 2 voire moins se
soigner à avoir des difficultés pour se
loger pour se nourrir pour éduquer ses
enfants
oui je pense qu'elle n'a pas d'avenir
elle n'a pas d'âge
forcément qu'est ce que vous voulez une
société comme ça eh bien elle produit
c'est ce qu'ils ont envie de la
combattre voyez vous donc évidemment
qu'elle est chez sans moi j'ai pas de
boule de cristal
1 ce que je sais c'est toutes les
sociétés qui ont été déçus auprès des
sociétés d'oppression d'exploitation et
bien oui elles ont été elles ont été
transformées elles ont été contestées
et on ne voit pas toujours très bien le
modèle que vous voulez opposé à celui
qui existe qui a s'est laissée pour
compte qui a ses propositions mais qui
qui fait vivre aussi beaucoup de monde
il ya quand même beaucoup de gens qui
tous les matins mon boulot nathalie
artaud ou dans cette partie moi aussi
mais qu'est ce que vous voulez dire leur
la grille à rien d'autre d'imagina
blavet je vous demande quel est votre
fille votre solution alternative
moi je suis communiste révolutionnaire
c'est à dire que j'ai bien cet idéal
l'a1 qu'on peut lui organiser l'économie
de façon collective sans en laisser la
direction à une minorité du simple fait
qu'elle a apporté les capitaux
et bien voilà qu'on laisse pas si vous
voulez la direction de ces grandes
entreprises
il ya 200 grandes entreprises en france
qui domine toute l'économie qui domine
les millions de petites entreprises de
pme dans le pays et ses 200 entreprises
et bien elles sont dirigées par des
conseils d'administration qui sont dans
les mains de quelques milliers de grands
actionnaires et qui décide pour tout le
monde
voilà qui imposent leur diktat à toute
la société eh bien nous nous sommes pour
qu'à la place de cette minorité qui
disent qu'ils décident si on met en
commun effectivement ces grands moyens
de production à commencer par les
banques
un don qui sommes-nous pour exproprier
effectivement les banquiers mettre en
commun un et fusionner toutes ces
banques et les faire fonctionner sous le
contrôle des employés de banques des
usagers des banques
collectivement voilà qui n'est pas un
conseil gagner
illustration comme ça qu'ils
fonctionnent secrètement pour les profit
égoïste d'une minorité
ça s'appelle we le communisme d'accord
alors c'est cet idéal qui a si vous
voulez animer les révolutionnaires de la
commune de paris
ici en france oui on écoute attentive
aux gens le temps référence vous ai
compris sur des jeux de boudin qui ont
animé aussi les révolutionnaires russe
de 1917 et qui vont commencer évidemment
à réaliser dans les premières années
cet idéal l'arrêt commune de paris c'est
là où il dit également la référence de
jean luc mélenchon je vous propose de
tout filmer en parler si vous êtes
d'accord jean luc mélenchon vous le
dites complémentaires de françois
hollande pourtant il a dit qu'il allait
poser des conditions pour son ralliement
au candidat socialiste vous ne le croyez
pas en l'occurrence pour le deuxième
tour il n'y a aucune condition pour
appeler à voter hollande au deuxième
tour il n'y a aucune condition il l'a
dit et redit c'était la règle du
désistement républicain jean luc
mélenchon jean luc mélenchon explique
qu'il y a de toute façon le désistement
républicain mais il a dit que ça n'était
pas à prendre ou à laisser comme l'a dit
sur notre antenne d'ailleurs le
socialiste jérôme cahuzac
il veut poser ses conditions pour un
effectivement pour un pacte de
gouvernement ou répartition pour les
législatives mais pour appeler hollande
au deuxième tour c'est automatique et
voiliers de de ce point de vue là
finalement il est en deçà de ce que de
ce qu'a obtenu europe ecologie les verts
puisque europe ecologie les verts vont
d'ores et déjà quand même justement posé
un certain nombre de conditions là c'est
effectivement le désistement donc leur
aliment complet 1 au deuxième tour voilà
finalement il amènera tous ces électeurs
qui sont critiques juste titre à mon
avis de hollande et bien les amènera à
faire élire hollande
voilà voilà pourquoi je parle de
complémentarité effectivement de
division du travail entre hollande et
mélenchon mais vous même avec votre
score assez réduit d'après les sondages
aujourd'hui autour de 1% aux électeurs
aussi ils voteront françois hollande au
second tour vous même
seul bulletin que vous mettrez dans
l'urne au second et vous attendrez soyez
patient sur moi c'est un bulletin c'est
que je mets dans reviendra au premier
tour
donc il faut être patient pour savoir
voilà second tour arrivera en temps et
en heure bien sûr mais on peut déjà en
parler et bien non justement
non parce que écouter cette campagne il
faut la faire et l'élection il faut la
faire aussi donc je suis désolé il ya
une campagne au premier tour on est dix
candidats on a chacun notre programme a
amené et moi c'est sûrement pas pour me
taire pour m'éclipser derrière untel ou
untel est sûrement pas derrière
d'ailleurs hollande 1 dont je ne vois
absolument pas en quoi son élection va
protéger les travailleurs des
licenciements des bas salaires du
chômage 1 quand je vois les engagements
de hollande c'est clair que hollande ne
s'engagent que vis-à-vis des banquiers
que les ai bien sûr écouté il a d'ores
et déjà expliqué hinx priorité c'est
effectivement de payer la dette 1 de
payer ses intérêts 50 milliards quand
même par an 1 et ça ça sera à payer
rubis sur ongle voilà et donc qu'est ce
que vous en faites si la dette est bien
la nef 700 milliards que oui 500
milliards de dettes supplémentaires la
sueur sur c'est sur ces cinq ans
effectivement et bien moi je dis que
cette dette c'est la dette de la
bourgeoisie stahel de payer tout
simplement voilà vous remboursez vos
dettes
je sais voilà moi aussi tous les
travailleurs qui ont des dettes 1 qui
sont endettés qu'ils ont empruntés ils
doivent payer travailleurs ils
empruntent pour leur voiture pour leur
logement à des fois même pour soigner
loyer ou pour payer les études de leurs
enfants et ils payent leurs dettes
et bien moi je dis que ce qu'ils ont
fait cette dette est ce qu'ils ont fait
cette dette c'est les banquiers safa les
gouvernements successifs c'est les
gouvernements sans débourser de l'argent
pour maintenir un certain modèle
peut-être non attendez c'est pas de
l'argent qui est allé ni dans les
hôpitaux ni dans les écoles ni dans les
retraites
aucun travailleur n'a vu la couleur de
cet argent c'est milliards ils ont été
mis sur la table pour les banquiers pour
les groupes de l'automobile ces lettres
ça a été la prime à la casse mais ça a
été aussi les exonérations en veux tu en
voilà de toutes sortes qui ont été qui
ont été mis et ses disques et annoncé 20
sur toutes les exonérations aux débris
est heureux sur les niches fiscales
françois hollande comme nicolas sarkozy
disent qu'ils vont fermer le robinet oui
bah écoutez moi j'ai surtout compris que
nicolas sarkozy a eu encore une idée
géniale un d'une exonération de
cotisations sociales pour les patrons
qui embaucheraient des plus de 55 ans
envoyé en corse et combien 3 4 5
milliards
alors soit disant il n'y a plus un euro
dans les caisses publiques mais là
encore il trouve quand même des
milliards de cadeaux à donner alors
voila moi cette dette je suis pour
qu'elles soient remboursées mais parce
qu'ils ont fait tout simple govou ne
fait pas de différences entre françois
hollande et nicolas sarkozy ce sont deux
adversaires
mon adversaire c'est bien sûr nicolas
sarkozy si c'est lui qui a été au
pouvoir c'est lui qui a couvert
finalement les et bien le diktat
patronal qui a justifié à chaque fois
les cookies sont tombés sur la tête des
travailleurs qui a fait le boulot qui a
tiré les marrons du feu pour pour les
grands groupes pour les plus riches
sur ces cinq ans donc c'est évidemment
lui mon adversaire et en même temps je
n'ai pas d'illusions
1 c'est pas parce que on a tout lieu de
deux
de vouloir se débarrasser de sarkozy que
je vais tomber dans les bras de hollande
un hollandais s'est engagé à rien
vis-à-vis des travailleurs excusez moi
mais y'a rien sur les salaires y a rien
pour s'opposer aux fermetures
d'entreprises n'y a rien pour obliger le
patronat embaucher et il faudrait qu'ils
embauchent parce qu'il ya quatre
millions et demi quand même de personnes
qui attendent un emploi aujourd'hui dans
le pays donc y'a rien les mesures que
vous trouvez insuffisante et qui
s'apparentent à rien selon vous un
nathalie arthaud dernière question qui
hante je vois même pas mais vous savez
sur un y compris quand il parle de
retraite à 60 ans écouté c'est retraite
à 60 ans pour ceux qui ont travaillé qui
ont cotisé quarante huit 48 qui ont
cotisé un papa seulement valider tout ça
ça se réduit et finalement ce sera une
toute petite minorité
un qui pourra espérer partir
effectivement à 60 ans donc non voilées
tout en promesse là vraiment c'est le
strict minimum et en plus en plus selon
lui nous explique que tout ça c'est
conditionné évidemment comme toujours à
la croissance c'est à dire que tout ça
c'est très hypothétique et contribuer ce
qui lui est des fruits de la croissance
mais écoutez les profits sont là il ya
73 milliards qui ont été réalisés quand
on entend on entend parler des exilés
fiscaux qu une enquête d'un journaliste
explique depuis 2000 il y a près de 600
milliards qui sont partis dans les
paradis fiscaux
excusez moi mais c'est pas l'argent qui
manque alors encore une question tient
sur mélenchon dit un mot pour le
défendre puisque laurence parisot l'a
présenté comme le candidat de la terreur
alors oui mais pas envie de descendre là
le candidat de la gauche explique est la
candidate de l'extrême complet où il
n'en faut pas beaucoup pour f pour pour
que les patrons hurle à la mort et en
faut pas beaucoup en général il suffit
de toucher à rome leurs cheveux pour
qu'ils eurent envoyé là dessus moi ça
c'est pas c'est pas là dessus que je me
cale ray non c'est moi je penserai
travers devrait devrait s'inspirer
finalement de ce que de ce que font les
patrons 1 dès qu'on touche à un petit
peu à leurs intérêts ici les urnes et
crie au secours au secours mais il
faudrait que les travailleurs fassent
pareil qui se défendent qui se laisse
pas faire alors en tous les cas on a des
exemples à prendre je crois
contrairement à jean luc mélenchon qui
prône la révolution par les urnes bouger
quand même compris que vous prenez la
révolution tout court nathalie arthaud
et alors on voit avec mounir souci que
c'est plus évidemment qu'une simple
différence de langage
si au ps le changement c'est maintenant
à lutte ouvrière le slogan serait plutôt
la révolution c'est pour quand le parti
est présent à chaque présidentielle
depuis 1974 pourtant l'élection n'est
pas une fin en soi
on est les seuls sans doute dans cette
élection à dire que le bulletin de vote
ne peut pas changer la vie ce qui peut
changer la vie c'est la vie des
travailleurs c'est leur lutte collective
le grand soir ne viendra donc pas par
les urnes mais grâce à la mobilisation
des ouvriers
vaste programme pourtant l'amérique
latine des expériences ont permis de
changer le système par le haut notamment
au venezuela
on a vu se développer depuis la chute du
mur de berlin depuis la fin de l'union
soviétique en 1991 d'autres mouvements
que l'on pourrait qualifier facilement
d'alternatif ailleurs que en europe faut
citer notamment le cas du venezuela et
on pourrait en citer d'autres idées
d'autres tentatives en amérique centrale
notamment le mouvement zapatiste au
mexique aussi sondé même moment un peu
qui se veulent la paix alternatif pour
le parti trotskiste les seuls moyens de
rompre avec le capitalisme sont
d'interdire les licenciements
de réquisitionner les logements vides ou
d'exproprier les grands groupes la lutte
des classes comme unique moteur
politique
l'expropriation en pratique c'est quoi
ben c'est que c'est plus les
actionnaires qui décide c'est puis les
actionnaires qui dirige cette entreprise
s'il l'on met en faillite ses basses et
des incapables
c'est à dire il faut que ça soit les
travailleurs qui prennent en main cette
entreprise faut que ça soit les
travailleurs que ce soit l'état
en tout cas faut plus que ce soit les
actionnaires mais imposer de tels
changements ne peut pas se faire sans
quelques accrocs révolution et non
violence c'est presque sûr c'est une
équation impossible
gandil a espéré quand il n'était pas un
marxiste avec moins de 1 % dans les
intentions de vote et un taux de
syndicalisation au plus bas lutte
ouvrière doit encore à battre quelques
murs avant d'entrevoir la révolution
prolétarienne voilà alors certes c'est
de l' agence france-presse
c'est avec ma famille bonsoir question à
nathalie arthaud je vais rebondir sur ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure à michel
grossiord arrête laguiller au soir du
premier tour de 2007 avait appelé à
voter pour ségolène royal françois
hollande est tellement pire que ça
pourrait placer ouvrière que ségolène
royal comme je l'avais dit c'était au
soir du premier tour donc attendez le
soir du gag de retour tous voulaient pas
me pardonner mais malgré la diatribe
anti hollande que nous venons d'entendre
vous n'excluez pas au soir du premier
tour d'appeler là encore une fois il
faudra être patient et voilà moi je veux
écouter ça suffit quand même depuis ce
samedi
ça fait des jeunes je sais pas presque
un an qu'on nous présente effectivement
un duel un parti socialiste n'a pas ce
que pour ces gens là d'accord que pour
leurs voix à eux
alors voila moi j'ai un programme à
défendre effectivement des idées des
convictions idéal donc je compte bien le
faire
je compte bien le faire et pas toujours
être jugés par rapport aux roues
voilà il s'agit de se voir aussi si vous
souhaitez cinq ans de plus avec nicolas
sarkozy ou une alternance qu'est-ce que
tu es ce que le plus favorable pour les
couvrir
évidemment que c'est non
mais nous on n'est pas ni pour limpide
la politique du pire et évidemment que
je souhaite pas cinq ans avec sarkozy
c'est évident et en même temps je sais
que se débarrasser de sarkozy ça ne
vaudra ça voudra toujours quand même
dire qu'on sera confronté à ce patronat
rapaces qui a qu'une seule et même
politique c'est de faire payer quand
même la crise des dégâts de la crise aux
travailleurs parce que c'est ça qui
s'est passé quand même pendant ses trois
années de crise c'est que ces messieurs
s'en sont sorti indemme avec tout leur
pouvoir avec leurs profits et on
garantit leurs dividendes à leurs
actionnaires et continue de le faire
mais ils l'ont fait en sacrifiant les
travailleurs en sacrifiant leur emploi
ils ont quand même fait un million de
chômeurs 1 et devront quand même se met
la misère et le chômage dans le pays
alors comme ça moi j'appelle ça une
politique patronale j'appelle ça la
lutte de classe et je suis bel et bien
convaincu que quel que soit le gagnant
de l'élection
cette lutte de classe elle va se
poursuivre qu'est ce que vous a déjà
entendu vous êtes souvent sous les
billets on entend ce discours qui a sans
doute des faux noms de deux vérités et
d'un fondeur militants qu'est ce que la
campagne vous apprendre très sincèrement
qu'est ce que michel roussillon vous
demander si vous aviez dans les usines
vous faites des déplacements vous
rencontrez les français plus peut-être
que dans votre activité militante
ordinaire qu'est ce qu'elle vous a
appris jusqu'à présent la campagne
oui c'est mon activité militante
ordinaires qui n'ont pas su éviter la
chance de vous déplacer tous les jours
dans différents coins de france et bien
voilà ce que moi ce qui ma perception de
la société française vous avez depuis
2007 quand ce n'est pas une nouvelle
réalité c'est une confirmation si vous
voulez à chaque fois que je vais dans
une ville ou dans une région
je peux faire une liste d'entreprises
petites et grandes qui ont licencié
tu peux faire une liste 1 dans toutes
les régions ce qu'on voit c'est des
hôpitaux qui se restructurent des
matières dont quelques fermes délit
n'avait pas une remontée c919 y avait
quelque chose depuis pas de terreau à
ccc ça c'est c'est une colère je peux
vous garantir qu'il ya une colère qui
s'accumulent 1 dans les classes
populaires que il ya un sentiment
d'injustice énorme quand on croise les
travailleurs du groupe paru vendu 1 qui
a été liquidée par le groupe hersant un
groupe quand même richissime familière
sang qui coule des jours heureux en
suisse à l'abri justement du fisc et
qui a décidé de mettre sur le carreau
les 1650 travailleurs de paruvendu et
tout ce qui a fabriqué le journal du
groupe et au print comareg vous dire
quand on rencontre ces travailleurs là
et je pense que le jamie l'effet trop
vite les arcelormittal
je peux vous dire qu'on sent la révolte
et la rage ou classer les principales
causes d'inscription allende à pôle
emploi temps dont vous êtes économise le
connaissez la principale cause les
pourcentages d'inscription à pôle emploi
ça peut être là ça peut être les cdd sa
poussette heures dans l'immense majorité
s'est laissée dd oui et alors si vous
zappez pas ça licenciement vous quand on
sait quand et les cds sont renvoyés moi
j'appelle ça un licenciement
quand on a des rumeurs est renvoyée
j'appelle ça un licenciement pour moi
c'est un licenciement voulait interdire
les licenciements venons si je suis vous
êtes vous est agrégé d'économie
si j'ai bien lu avez vous un exemple
dans l'histoire économique récente dans
le pays d'enhaut économie actuelle de
nos mises en pratique de cette mesure et
de ses résultats
est-ce que vous pouvez l'évaluer non je
n'ai pas d'exemple et il faut pas vous
en étonnez de partout c'est la même
classe capitaliste qui devraient
circuler
c est ce qu ils sont libres et son livre
d'un responsable politique avec une
parole responsable
est ce que c'est c'est prudent de prôner
une musique et une une mesure pardon qui
n'a jamais mais jamais été mise en
pratique vous êtes en train de me dire
que ce qui n'a jamais été mis en
pratique ne peut pas exister alors nous
on est prêts on est coincé tout impact
très bien parier sur place ben justement
candidats en économie quand on lance une
mesure inédite on fait d'abord des
études d'impact presse que vous auriez
est ce que vous avez dans vos modèles
économiques mise en place par vos
commissions je suis vous êtes un parti
très sérieux de très structuré avec des
ressources intellectuelles très sérieux
très très riches non plus là pour en
revenir à quelques questions
est-ce que vous avez vous est ce que
vous avez fait tourner un modèle
économique avec des interdictions de
licenciement et quels sont les résultats
écoutez des études d'impact comme vous
dites on en fait depuis 40 ans sur leur
politique mais ben oui et j'ai quand
même droit parole
qu'est-ce que vous avez tué notre
mission essentielle n'est ce pas est ce
que c'est ce que répète d'asphyxié
exclusion une grande mais les études
d'impact de leur politique a eu de la
droite et de la gauche qui consiste
systématiquement en matière de chômage a
incité le patronat à les aider à
embaucher en mettant des cadeaux des
millions de cadeaux sur la table en
disant ne payez plus de cotisations pour
eux alors on paye flux pour les
handicapés on paye plus pour les jeunes
en payent plus pour les smicards et et
est embauché
est-ce qu'ils embauchent ils n'ont
annoncé par le premier mais ça c'est une
40 ans qui font cette politique était
mené campagne en fait campagne sur ces
même pas et bien moi je faisais ma
étudier l'éventuelle application il n'y
a pas besoin de l'étudier excusez moi
alors il faudrait interdire les
licenciements
bien sûr que ça arrête tous les
licenciements d'intérimaires chez psa
chez lars eller tout ça de côté et on le
fait mais ça relève mille chômeurs
le stage doit rentrer chez eux alors
sept noms sept vite pas le stock mais ça
arrête sa ferme le robinet le voyez vous
et là il n'y a pas besoin de faire de
grands dresseurs tôt il y a nommé je
continue là dessus il ya mille chômeurs
de plus tous les jours et s'effectuer
les cds des jeux tous ces faits et les
intérimaires
n'empêche écoutez chaque mois nous avons
300 milles effectivement ce soit au
niveau des flux d'autres souvent des
fumées vous savez quand même comme moi
vous avez quand même comme moi que le
chômage ne fait que monter un d'accord
et qu'il ya eu un million de chômeurs de
plus sur cinq ans veut dire que c'est un
une hémorragie qu'il faut arrêter donc
ça si vous voulez c'est une mesure de
bon sens et j'ai pas besoin de tirer des
plans sur la comète pour dire que la
première chose à faire quand on veut
combattre le chômage c'est d'arrêter les
licenciements justement alors alors on
arrête des licenciements et je peux vous
garantir que mais tous les deux sont les
moyens de garantir les l'entreprise perd
hélas tous ses marchés malheureusement
ce soit fréquemment les salariés sont là
et n'ont plus de boulot avec des
machines s'arrêtent ils restent dans
l'entreprise selon votre chemin
il a qu'est ce qu'ils font ils restent
dans l'entreprise y font eh bien ils
sont payés mais ils sont payés à coiffer
sans payer s'il appelait fonde ci a plus
de marché
il n'y a plus de marché mais il ya plus
de travail
alors n'y a plus de marché c'est pas
leur faute c'est pas leur faute on est
d'accord il faut quand même qu'ils
crèvent j'ai peut-être en train de nos
diamants si vous attendez on veut dire
ça non vous êtes en train de me dire ils
ont et les dirigeants sont ils aussi en
descendant de me dire ça les dirigeants
sont des incapables
les idées et les dirigeants n'ont plus
de marché ils savent plus quoi avant
d'exercer conduire etc
leur économie est complètement dingue
mais les travailleurs et ben ils ont cas
ils ont qu'à aller crever un au chômage
parce que c'est ça c'est une
condamnation au chômage moi je dis que
dans ces groupes là et là il s'agit de
on parle de psa on parle d'
arcelormittal des groupes qui font
encore des profits excusez moi mais même
été forcée pas de toutes les entreprises
alors mes commencé quand même parler des
commençants lancé grands entrepreneurs
font des profits dont vous avez entendu
parler quand même qu'ils fermer des
usines qui programmait des licenciements
vous en avez entendu parler
le sait bien tous ces groupes là moi je
dis que oui ils doivent c'est une
obligation qu'on doit leur faire et leur
imposer de garder leurs salariés
d'entreprises réaliser mon fils qui est
censé exactement une règle générale dont
oui mais aussi d'une grève
une règle que général aussi qu'il faut
aussi imposé aux pme aux pme comme
faurecia comme valeo
comme tout ces pme qui gravitent autour
de ces groupes et qui ont aussi beaucoup
certaines beaucoup d'argent ou alors bas
qui on peut dire eh bien allons prendre
chez le donneur d'ordres l'argent qu'il
faut mais vous comprenez écouter quand
on est dans la situation que vous
décrivez les actionnaires la cie y
compris la situation vous dites il ya
plus de comment lancer une marche au
prix s'est située à les actionnaires qui
ont qui sont encore payés qui ont encore
leurs dividendes
et puis qu'ils ont accumulés est ce que
ça leur pose un problème e1 d'en toucher
un petit peu moins voire de ne plus du
tout en toucher ça leur pose aucun
problème
ils ont un matelas haut ils ont un mac
là ils ont fait ils ont eu pour souci
pour est ce que pour vous le mot
compétitivité est un gros mot
la compétitivité de l'économie française
la compétitivité des entreprises
c'est un mot patronale ça si évident et
c'est toujours pour imposer et bien des
sacrifices aux travailleurs alors moi
j'ai rien contre le fait que les
entreprises baissent leurs prix
aucun problème mais elles peuvent aussi
baissé leurs prix en
union les marges voilà les marges
bénéficiaires en rognant sur les profits
parce que quand même il ya comme quelque
chose qui doit vous interpeller en tant
que grand économiste moi je ne considère
pas que c'est quand l'économie
non mais tu sais j'ai des clous c'est
quand même quelque chose qui doit nous
interpeller
c'est comme en cette période de crise un
catastrophique là comment ces gens là
arrive à préserver leur fortune et
comment il arrive à présenter 73
millions moi ça me guignard alors que
113 milliards pour lui comment il arrive
t-il ce qui m'interpelle encore une fois
c'est comment une agrégée d'économie peu
défend peut faire campagne sur des
mesures fortes qui semble assez
déconnectés de la réalité
l'autre mesure que vous préconisez si je
me souviens bien c'est le contrôle des
entreprises par par les travailleurs
c'est cela a l'air bon on peut avoir un
modèle c'est peut-être les soviets de
1917 où la yougoslavie de tito
c'est à dire que ce soient des modèles
qui ont été qui ont laissé un souvenir
économique intérêts intériste dans
l'histoire ou écouter ans on peut en
discuter du modèle économique est
compris un de l'union soviétique dans
les années 30 40
on pourrait en discuter de la net vous
savez oui mais on bouffe économie
soviétique a été de nouveau obligé de
s'ouvrir aux capitaux étrangers
on peut on peut en discuter vous savez
il ya une industrialisation union
soviétique justement l'art l'eau en
l'occurrence ans sans la bourgeoisie
voyez sans ce qui a porté les capitaux
ils ont développé une économie
différente bah écoutez moi ça
m'intéresse et compris de regarder ça
mais voyez vous dites ce contrôle et moi
ça me paraît être quelque chose de bon
sens
excusez moi mais les travailleurs qui
font tourner une entreprise qui la font
vivre qui font à sa richesse vous
trouvez anormal qu'il puisse savoir
exactement l'argent qui vient dans les
andes en langue russe ça ça vous choque
que les travailleurs quand même titi qui
la font tourner l'entreprise puisse
savoir qu'elle est l'argent réellement
dans l'autre ce qui s'y passe à ce que
l'on puisse dire sans salaire ce que le
travail rapporte ce qu'elles versent en
dividendes ce qu'elle met en provisions
ce qu'elle met de côté pour essayer de
racheter son concurrent en quoi ça vous
choque que les travers puisse avoir et
ça ce qui m'interpelle c'est que vous
envisagez aucune demi-mesure par exemple
vous vous parlez du contrôle des
entreprises par
par les travailleurs il y a il y à la
transparence
il ya des échelles intermédiaire il ya
le statut de coopérative qui sont des
démarches volontaires il y à la
cogestion à l'allemande
est ce que c est ce que sur cd par
exemple est-ce que la cogestion pour
vous et un est un gros mot le fait que
des travailleurs représentés par leurs
syndicats puissent gérer leur entreprise
avec le patronat c'est sa constitution
on prend bien
si je comprends bien que les
travailleurs puissent contrôler l'argent
les décisions les discussions les
projets qui sont en cours dans
l'entreprise ça vous apparaît être une
mesure extrémistes c'est ça non pas du
tout à grande échelle et celle du jour
au lendemain comme son maître normal et
même je vais vous dire ce qui me
semblerait normal c'est que non
seulement les travailleurs puissent le
savoir et même la population pense que
oui les grands groupes comme total qui
vont forer à quoi 4 5 kilomètres en
dessous de la terre que ces choix là
soit aussi proposé la population avec
les risques qu'on puisse décider
ensemble c'est quand même des décisions
pourquoi sont elles laissées dans la
main d'une minorité ça nous concerne
tous les dégâts c'est quand même bien
nous qui les payons donc moi je
trouverais ça ça me paraissait pas être
être du bon sens quelque chose si c'est
ça pour moi la démocratie c'est que ces
décisions là qui pèsent sur nos vies
quotidiennes
eh bien on les connaissent et qu'on
puisse donner notre avis aussi dessus on
voit pas en quoi ça vous choque plus
question mais c'est passionnant nous
sommes soudés sur le sujet des finances
passionnés sur des sujets politiques
olivier besancenot hier vous l'avez
entendu a souhaité en cas de victoire de
françois hollande
il a souhaité la constitution d'une
opposition sociale et politique à la
gauche du gouvernement il a souhaité que
vous en soyez vous en seriez avec sa
stratégie d'aller vers l'explosion
sociale ou de peser sur le gouvernement
pour qu'il mène une vraie politique de
gauche c'est pas une stratégie d'aller
vers l'expérience sociale cesser les
patrons eux mêmes qui vont là ils sont
ils sont assis sur un volcan
cc c'est eux qui en sont issus
continuerons-nous éthique avec québec
jean dumur on n'a pas la même politique
jean-luc mélenchon besancenot on a tous
la même politique d'ailleurs je
comprends pas pourquoi sont pas avec le
front de gauche est à vrai dire nous on
n'a pas la même politique que le front
de gauche donc donc c'est évident on
peut être ensemble dans les
manifestations dans les graines et en
ajoutant on n'a pas l'air d'accord qu'à
chacun défendre céline et je vois pas le
problème mais encore une dernière action
si ça va payer
eneria question qui est un peu politique
ça peut vous pourriez vous m'expliquer
cette curiosité pourquoi nous avons deux
partis trotskystes en france alors qu'il
y en a presque pas ailleurs dans le
monde et deuxième question c'est nier
les trotskistes et les trotskistes enfin
les entre ceux qui rêvaient de la
révolution dans plusieurs pays il était
cosmos qui l'opposait à staline et or
vous dans toutes les mesures que vous
avancez vous n'envisagez à aucun moment
contrairement à beaucoup d'autres
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
des alliances avec des partis frères
mais vous êtes assez mal renseignés
parce que le npa n'est n'est pas un
parti qui se revendiquent de trotski un
plus un parti qui servirent de trop du
fis donc je vous rassure il n'y en a
plus qu'un général appliquant ces luttes
ouvrières oui nous sommes nous
communistes d'ailleurs moi je m'en
réclame ouvertement effectivement une
société organisée collectivement qu'on
mette en commun les banques voilà les
grands moyens de production voilà et je
veux m'en aller je suis la seule à moi
réclamé alors voilà c'est comme ça
et par ailleurs salué la révolte la
révolte regardez ce qui se passe dans le
monde arabe
1 les révoltes elles ont été contagieuse
bas nous on pense que c'est ce qui se
passera s'il ya une révolte profonde
dans un pays
eh bien oui elle sera contagieuse dans
les autres pays mais là encore c'est
plus les patrons si vous voulez qu'ils
oeuvrent que nous nous les
révolutionnaires font le boulot à notre
place alors on a compris ils sont forts
vous avez déjà compris
à force et d'écraser à la population oui
merci merci samir comme fille pour avoir
apporté aussi brillamment la
contradiction sûr qu'une thèse
développée par lutte ouvrière nathalie
arthaud 1 moccia sur la taxation n'en a
pas parlé
nicolas sarkozy veut augmenter un petit
peu la taxation des hauts revenus un
petit peu j'ai dit françois hollande
il veut créer une nouvelle tranche à 45%
et à 75% au-delà de 1 million d'euros
jean luc mélenchon lui prend tout au
dessus de 350000 euros par part vous
vous prenez tout à partir de combien
non mais
on veut des salaires dignes donc on
prend en pension par augmenter les
salaires le smic à 1700 euros et
forcément ça prendra sur leurs profits
bon parce que le problème c'est pas de
prendre aux plus riches c'est à m au
plus haut vos travailleurs de vivre
normalement donc d'augmenter les
salaires les pensions de retraite des
petites gens et les impôts des riches
on pourra imposer bien mais pas dessus
je suis pas contre mais d'abord et
surtout faire mais voilà les gens
puissent remplir leur frigo perrine
tarneaud de public sénat va nous
rejoindre mais d'abord avec tam tran huy
on voit comment ça se passe avec bah
justement les parties que l'on croit
frère qui ne sont pas totalement et la
rencontre aidé certains de vos camarades
on va les appeler comme ça du npa qui
voudraient bien lutté certain en tout
cas à vos côtés même s'il trouve votre
fonctionnement va dire un petit peu
opaque quand tu es en quelque sorte la
légende crise de loot ouvrière seraient
fondées les partis de la gauche
révolutionnaire non plus la cote
qu'il s'agisse du npa ou de lutte
ouvrière il ne dépasse pas pour
l'instant 1% d'intentions de vote
ah il est bien loin le temps béni
d'arlette laguiller d'olivier besancenot
l'époque où la lcr et lutte ouvrière à
theniet ensemble les 10 % en 2002 bon
arlette laguiller l'albert fait d'écran
olivier besancenot ils ont fait un
million de voix succéder à des gens très
connus et très populaire c'est vrai que
probable verte au fait c'est une tâche
n'est pas facile
malgré leur mauvais sondages les deux
dernières formations de la gauche
trotskiste ne sont pas prêtes de
s'allier je t'aime moi non plus un amour
à sens unique voilà qui résume leur
relation le nouveau parti
anticapitaliste se verrait bien lutter
au quotidien avec lutte ouvrière et avec
bien d'autres
mais la réciproque n'est pas vraie mois
leur poche mais très fraternel qu'on
fait lutte ouvrière fait pas intéressé
dans les cadres unitaires au niveau des
mobilisations que ça sera sur la dette à
défendre et d'immigrés l'épreuve la
retraite etc
si la critique se fait du bout des
lèvres et avec le sourire chez les
cadres du npa
les militants deux étages plus bas sont
beaucoup plus franc du collier même une
lutte défensive
victorieuse on la gagnera pas son parti
communiste enfants nous le syndicaliste
sans les milliers de syndicalistes cgt
s'en doutait un peu même de mon fera pas
on va pas mener des luttes qui avec des
révolutionnaires
c'est ridicule alors oui chez les
camarades du npa on trouve la position
de nathalie arthaud pas très enviable
mais pas seulement parce qu'elle est
dans l'ombre d'arlette laguiller
c'est une tâche assez rude c'est vrai
d'être porte parole et surtout de
peut-être spécialement de lutte ouvrière
peut-être j'imagine qu'on peut - faire
de faux-pas répression mais les
militants ici sont peut-être quand même
au npa ce sont plus vivre quand même je
pense de s'exprimer d'avoir des petites
divergences d'analysé de la situation et
s'éteint alors lutte ouvrière un brin
dogmatique pas très ouvert peut-être la
face cachée de l'indépendance
révolutionnaire bonsoir nathalie arthaud
alors bonsoir lutte ouvrière
organisation dogmatique
écoutez ce paquet ce qui me frappe moi
dans ce reportage
c'est que finalement et il explique voit
la lutte ouvrière finalement reste dans
son coin
bon mais la réalité ils la connaissent
c'est qu'on est de toutes les
mobilisations de toutes les
manifestations contre les retraites
évidemment à chaque fois qu'il ya une
mobilisation pour défendre le droit de
vote des travailleurs immigrés la
régularisation des sans papiers on est
toujours là et on est évidemment pour on
est de tous les combats et en même temps
et en même temps dans les combats on
pense qu'elle la place pour toutes les
idées c'est à dire qu'on n'ait pas envie
d'être tous alliés d'alors - même point
de vue d'envoyer on n'est pas
automatique au contraire on pense qu'on
peut être ensemble dans les luttes et en
même temps me défendre des politiques
très différentes et laisser choisir
alors voyez il reproche sa finalement le
tour est alors que au contraire c'est
notre point de vue mais toujours est il
qu'il reste un peu toujours cette image
opaque voire de sectes dans sa lutte
ouvrière fantasme c'est beau fantasme un
là moi je peux pas je peux rien contre
ça c'est pas les fantasmes des
journalistes c'est peut-être parce que
vous manquer d'ouverture au grand public
alors quoi dites moi pourquoi vous ne
voulez jamais parler vraiment de
l'organisation
vous ne voulez jamais vous parler en
tant que candidate de votre vie privée
ou non excusez moi alors là ça n'a rien
à voir
salut bah oui j'ai trouvé c'est un peu
quand même parce que comme on dit je
vous dirai jamais figé non ça j'adore
franchement je pensais pas c'est jaune
c'est parce que je les retire c'est que
vous n'avez d'ailleurs déclaré dans le
monde ce week-end que les problèmes
personnels les choix personnels sont
défaillants politique le mariage oui
l'union libre sont des choix privé mais
ce sont également des problèmes
politiques
alors là franchement c'est intrigant
vous avez mal lu l'article
ce ne sont pas mes mots ce ne sont pas
mes mots c'est entre guillemets c'est la
journaliste qui a dit ça ce ne sont pas
mes mots pareils parce que les preuves
les chemins privés sont des problèmes
politiques à gauche ouvrière où nous
avons des positions des idées sur
effectivement beaucoup de choses y
compris la libre et les nounous somme
pour l'union libre nous sommes pour le
mariage homosexuel
nous sommes plutôt favorable pour le
droit de mourir dans la dignité voyez le
siège numéro sexuelle ne veut pas le
pour le mariage est homosexuel nous
sommes m'attendais à ce que vous
affirmez vous dites l'union livre
comprenez bien je comprends que vous
découvriez peut-être des gens qui sont
pour l'union lit mais c'est à dire qu'en
fait nous on voit pas vous savez c'est
brassens
1 pourquoi voilà à mettre son nom au bas
d'un parchemin n'est ce pas voilà
maintenant on n'a rien contre le fait
que jean se marie et d'ailleurs nous
disons que ce qui les couples
homosexuels qui le désirent peuvent
seulement que la moutarde et des choses
ici et aux deux buts le voyant ce n'est
pas l'action des choix privé à chaque
fois ça normal des choses je rêvais d
medica on parle de la vie privée mais
justement c'est là c'est là que l'enfant
de viozan choix politique c'est là que
ça devient une confusion on peut avoir
un point de vue sur bien des aspects de
la vie privée et en même temps et
évidemment qu'on est libre et tous nos
choix
tous nos choix c'est justement des choix
pour la liberté des choix progressiste
de laissé chacun libre de ses choix
c'est toutes nos positions c'est ça
alors qu'elle est en train de me dire
vous êtes en train de me dire que quoi
une partie va imposer des choses à ses
militants ça ça vous êtes en train de me
dire eh bien
elle est restée sept militants donner la
vie hier vous devez renoncer à toute vie
privée vient non madame c'est bien ce
que je vous disais là il s'agit de
fantasmes donc il faut comprendre les
choses vous ne renoncez pas là c'est un
secret dans votre vie privée là il y
avait une autre citation vous allez
pouvoir dire qu'elle était inexact le
même mes parents ne savent pas tout
parce que vous dites tous à vos parents
je suis conscient pas tout non moi
depuis très très jeune effectivement je
suis plutôt secrète mais je crois que
c'est son entrée sur personnaliser
il a écouté non je raconterai pas tout à
fait par an quand j'avais 14 15 ans
peut-être que vous si je sais que bon
dans certaines peut-être certaines
familles ça se fait mais non mais ça
c'est bon en tout cas liés à des clients
face à leïla et dans votre vie pour
faire autre chose que de militer siens
mais je vous rassure je suis normal vous
pouvez voilà je suis retrouvé j'ai plus
de temps libre même que vous même
j'espère pourquoi voilà voilà
mais qu'elles sont des loisirs noté
lierse est par exemple tombé dans une
campagne c'est aussi une rencontre entre
un homme une femme et les français donc
il faut qu'ils aient envie d'avoir envie
de quelqu'un pour voter pour lui sinon
alors être un petit peu là je ne crois
pas un journal je crois qu'il faut
surtout que effectivement je mets en
avant mes idées c'est un accord sur mes
idées c'est ceux qui auront envie de
dire la même chose que moi qui voteront
pour moi maintenant je suis normal voilà
je suis je suis dans un club sportif et
la natation
j'ai des amis du cinéma je suis
passionnée avec la manière sans prendre
j'ai fais des footings ton dieu voilà je
voyais
voilà je suis tout à fait normaux michel
qui est très soutenu de votre santé
demande si vous faites toujours tout
comme ça avec cette terre très tonique
sans respirer non mais là il faut dire
que vous m'avez quand même un peu mis
sur le gril 80 il ya un sondage qui est
tombé live l'occasion de la foire de
paris figurez-vous 84% des français se
voient joyeux est ce que c'est votre
père mais coûté en tout cas moi je me
vois surtout d'une confiance c'est sûr
indéfectible en l'humanité voilà et je
suis convaincu que qu'on arrivera à
résoudre les problèmes voilà les
problèmes énormes de notre économie de
notre société
je suis convaincu qu'on peut aller de
l'avant 1 et que tout ce que vous me
dites ouh là là mais il faut pas on peux
rien imaginer d'autres de différent
l'inconnu ou l'annoncé que rien que
parce qu'on vous dit je suis convaincu
au contraire que tout ça on peut on peut
inventer et on peut améliorer bien des
choses je voulais revenir sur leur
partage convient de regarder on écoutait
cette militante du npa qui avait l'air
soucieuse pour vous si votre score
n'était pas très satisfaisant au premier
tour elle parle de répression c'est vrai
ça elle a parlé de répression dre et
bien écoutez
bon ben voilà c'est ce qu'on a c'est son
point de vue bah vous verrez c'est en
capter un tassement de penser je vais
être pendus
non mais écoutez franchement c'est est
ce que vous êtes fixé un objectif coûté
pour le premier tour pour votre score
onze noms n'a pas d'objectif non non non
non non pas avoir une ambition atteindre
5% par exemple notre ambition c'est de
faire comprendre justement nos idées
faire comprendre ce qu'on est de faire
comprendre nos perspectives c'est de
pouvoir effectivement les les diffuser à
grande échelle 1 montrer justement qui
en a qui seraient ils pas qu'ils ont
pour vite se laisser faire qui
contestent la société qui sont prêts
effectivement à à dire eh bien voilà le
chemin qu'on nous montre dont on dit il
faut pas en sortir et bien si la réalité
c'est qu'on peut changer ça voilà il ya
eu des révolutions il ya eu des révoltes
tout ça cc devant nous à oui voilà c'est
de faire entendre ça et vous savez moi
je suis convaincu que ça tombe pas dans
l'oreille de sourds je ne sais pas
combien iront voter pour ma candidature
mais ça tombe pas dans l'oreille de
sourds ça tombe dans l'oreille de gens
quand même qu'ils se posent des
questions sur ce qui se passe dans la
société et qui se sentent c'est compris
condamné quand même par la société parce
que vous savez quand on retrouve au
chômage aujourd'hui on se dit qu'on a
plus d'avenir dans cette société
un conte et qu'on ait laissé de côté un
conte a plus de vie donc je peux vous
garantir que tous hâte aux auteurs eh
bien ça portera ses fruits
donc nous c'est effectivement ça c'est
porter nos idées c'est les défendre et
voilà montrer qu'il y en a qui se
résignent pas et qui sont prêts à aller
de l'avant
on vous a beaucoup comparé à vos débuts
à arlette laguiller qui a une certaine
ressemblance physique est ce que c'est
on vous a pesé est ce que ben voilà
ressemblance physique sans doute non
mais ce que ça faisait peser d'être cool
souvent comparé à l'adq laguiller qui
est quand même une figure tutélaire de
l'élection présidentielle en france à la
été six fois candidate non non non pas
du tout et je dois vous dire que pour
moi ça me fait plutôt plaisir ça me fait
plaisir et elle voulait donner des
conseils au bain bien sûr et puis c'est
une facilité parce que ce n'est le point
par exemple elle m'a elle m'a ouvert la
voie moi je pense qu'effectivement quand
je parle je suis assez identifié
justement un mois par l'armée dans le
camp des travailleurs on n'a jamais
retourner notre veste jamais trahi
jamais
changer changer de politique donc voila
et puis évidemment oui elle me conseille
à l'ecoute les interviews mais le guen
place importante dans votre parcours
politique
oui bien sûr bien sûr évidemment elle a
incarné lutte ouvrière elle a beaucoup
compté elle continue de compter merci à
vous nathalie arthaud de votre présence
aujourd'hui encore on vous reçoit
régulièrement sur la chaîne publique
c'est vrai il faut le dire à 22h30 il ya
un autre rendez vous avec preuves par 3
est notre invité sera jean pierre
raffarin tout à l'heure donc en tous les
cas on se retrouve dans quelques minutes
pour le journal de 19h bonsoir à tous
quel est l'impact d'un grand équipement
sur les habitants et les acteurs locaux
après le viaduc de millau public sénat
s'intéresse au futuroscope de poitiers
retour sur ces grands travaux qui ont
bouleversé nos territoires
attention grands travaux jeudi à 23h sur
public sénat d'une campagne à l'autre
cette semaine en aveyron à la rencontre
des blouses blanches de l'hôpital de
millau des infirmières attaché au
service public
notre docteur en sondages nous lira
ensuite c'est les salariés du public
reste fidèle à la gauche enfin
l'immersion dans la section ump de rodez
des militants requinqué par les bons
sondages l'hôpital public doit se
réformer autour d'un double objectif la
qualité des soins et l'optimisation des
moyens c'est ce que déclarait nicolas
sarkozy fin 2007 depuis la loi bachelot
a profondément modifié le mode de
financement des hôpitaux publics
désormais soumis aux mêmes règles que le
privé restructuration baisses
d'effectifs fréquentation en hausse
l'hôpital peinent aujourd'hui à trouver
sa voie entre missions de service public
et équilibre budgétaire d'une campagne à
l'autre direction
l'aveyron est un département rural où
les hôpitaux se bat pour ne pas fermer
rencontre avec cécile et florence
infirmière au centre hospitalier de
millau
c'est parti
voilà presque 30 ans que les journées de
florence commence de la même façon on
parle de tous les malades par an
explique à la matinée ce qui s'est passé
en apparence rien n'a changé même geste
même concentration mais avec un budget
plus serré et des patients plus nombreux
ça roule beaucoup ça change les passages
plus vite leur propre record autrefois y
rester pour une petite appendicite par
exemple peut on rester une semaine
maintenant rester trois jours donc les
patients sortait en a d'autres karine ça
va très vite
je vous prends la température florence
regrette qu'elle millau comme ailleurs
la rentabilité soit devenu un impératif
depuis 2008 et la mise en place de la
tarification à l'activité
les hôpitaux publics et privés sont
soumis aux mêmes règles comptables et
les économies sont partout si ce qu'on
met sur les percées vision pour les
maintenir
on en avait un qui était très bien avec
les gens nous en a mis l'homme qui est
de moins bonne qualité qui tiennent bien
moins on amuseurs pas score donc
l'économie charolais un temps menacé est
les services de maternité et de
chirurgie semble aujourd'hui sorti
d'affaires
depuis la fermeture de la seule clinique
privée de la ville
l'activité des services est même reparti
à la hausse contre j'ai besoin de savoir
qui vous souhaitez combat ambulance en a
absorbé plus activité chirurgicale avec
quasiment le même nombre de l'ip
je vais là c'est ce qui fait qu'il ya
certains jours de la semaine en fonction
de l'activité programmée qu'on a m d
urgence qui arrive
derrière on n'arrive pas à faire face
quoi alors voilà en permanence on doit
jouer les entrées les sorties c'est
d'anticiper maximum ou va fixer un peu
les dates pour les groupes de travail
faire tourner le service céline
ghesquière et cadres infirmiers
c'est elle qui fait les plannings et
elle a parfois bien du mal à remplir les
cases faute de personnel à 1450 euros
nets en début de carrière
les candidates ne sont pas nombreuses au
quotidien les infirmières soient soumis
à prendre des décisions et parfois ça
peut faire peur il faut des gens qui ont
réel sainteté responsabilités et tous
les jours vous l'a engagé une fois les
visites terminées florence doit encore
aller au bloc opératoire
malgré l'accélération du rythme malgré
des rémunérations juste suffisante
malgré les gardes malgré des nuits elle
reste attachée à cet hôpital à taille
humaine dont les familles les familles
11 venir nous parler que des fraudes
avec les hôpitaux elles sont perdues où
elles viennent nous voir elle nous parle
on parle mais les patients c'est plus
facile pour eux et pour nous
17h appelé en urgence l'hélicoptère du
samu l'école de millau à son bord une
urgence vitale dans 15 minutes il sera
au chu de montpellier par la route il
aurait fallu plus d'une heure et demie
avant de prolonger
on se retrouve avec céline et florence
dans le service de chirurgie viscérale
rebond journée dames 1 alors quand vous
retirez vos blouses blanches est ce que
vous prenez le temps de vous intéresser
à la politique
moi personnellement très peu moins un
petit peu quel regard vous portez
aujourd'hui sur ce monde politique
on les voit beaucoup dans les querelles
entre eux et c'est vrai que ça m'a on a
l'impression qu'il manque un peu
du ried et en plus je trouve qu'il
manque des personnes des personnages
forts charismatique la dernière élection
présidentielle c'était en 2007 à
l'époque pour qu'ils vous aviez choisi
de voter
j'avais voté parti socialiste et vous
mais moi les centres par des fous parce
qu'en fait sur le parti socialiste et je
l'avais trouvé personne qui m'avait
donné envie de voter pour lui je trouve
que c'est important en fait un président
de la république et moi je m'identifie
comme ça n'a pas forcément cogiter alors
florence ou travailler ici où depuis 27
ans vous céline depuis 17 ans vous avez
vu les choses changent et comment a
changé a évolué votre quotidien
mais on fait plus attention aux dépenses
aux économies on nous parle beaucoup de
la tarification à l'acte
vous avez le sentiment que le
gouvernement a voulu aider la santé ces
cinq dernières années ou pas non j'étais
à tfz je crois qu'en fait on est
vraiment rentré dans une démarche où
l'économique est important on est un peu
gérer plus comme une entreprise alors
qu'à l'hôpital c'était pas du tout ça
autrefois dans notre quotidien c'est on
n'avait pas ce qu'on l'avait - stoke on
trent la wii
ces variations le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle approche est
ce que vous trouvez qu'on parle bien de
la santé jusqu'ici j'ai pas trop en
tenue de choses sur la ceinture si elle
est une décision qui devait être prise
que ce soit pour votre travail votre
quotidien demain ça serait quoi serait
important pour vous garder les hôpitaux
de proximité
on en a besoin surtout dans nos
départements qui sont très étendus il ya
beaucoup de personnes âgées et la
médecine de proximité
c'est quand même important pour eux pour
leurs familles est ce que vous savez
déjà pour qui vous allez voter au mois
de mai moi je ne sais pas encore
exactement mais pas à droite
voilà là franchement pour l'instant je
sais pas voilà mais ça serait plutôt à
gauche également florence céline merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions